[Musica]
se esattamente un anno fa a quest'ora mi
avessero detto sofia farà una grande
stagione
otterrai ben tre podi in coppa del mondo
avrei subito firmata occhi chiusi
bendata sentivo dentro di me l'estate
scorsa di aver fatto delle scelte che mi
avevano portato a un grado di
consapevolezza maggiore ma mai e poi mai
mi sarei aspettata di farne 11 podi due
vittorie e di ottener l'unica medaglia
ai campionati del mondo nella spedizione
dallo sci alpino è solo quando le cose
finiscono che si realizza veramente il
loro valore si riesce ad avere una
visione completa olistica dall insieme e
io ho realizzato di aver fatto una
grandissima stagione una stagione
eclatante straordinario solo nel finale
dopo aver fatto l'ultimo podio
all'ultima gara il 19 marzo podio che
tra l'altro condiviso anche con due
altri miei compagni e brignone bassino
abbiamo fatto l'ump len italiana è stata
una giornata incredibile quando io
risultato in quel momento ho alzato le
braccia al cielo e quello è stato il
gesto conclusivo di questa mia magnifica
stagione e sapevo dentro di me che prima
di poter far di nuovo quel segno in per
risultare avrei dovuto aspettare mesi la
prossima stagione
in quel momento ho realizzato veramente
che la mia stagione era finita
non sapevo quello che mi avrebbe
aspettato di lì a poco anche se a dir la
verità alcuni allenatori mi avevano
avvertito che una volta rientrati in
italia probabilmente avrà avuto un
assalto mediatico non indifferente
avevo sempre preso un po la legge va
comunque le loro parole perché dopotutto
è riuscita a convivere con un cellulari
continuava a squillare dalla seconda
fino all'ultima gara continuando a far
sempre le mie gare dando il meglio di me
ogni giorno vi dico che il 20 marzo non
ho neanche avuto il tempo di atterrare a
malpensa di ritirare le mie valigie che
già una macchina mi stava scortando ad
una conferenza stampa a milano su stata
cinque ore in una terrazza a rispondere
alle mille domande dei giornalisti per
lo più tutte uguali sono stata poi
portata in un salotto televisivo grasso
sera e la mattina dopo alle 7 di mattina
ero già in collegamento via a facetime e
in un'altra trasmissione televisiva in
meno di un giorno in meno di quelli che
sono ventiquatt'ore sono entrate in
quello che io definisco il vortice
quando ci entri nel vortice te ne
accorgi ma inevitabile
mentre lo sottovaluti perché dopo otto
mesi che poi sempre le stesse cose è
sempre una stessa routine vedi sempre le
stesse persone colazione pranzo cena ti
alleni con le stesse ragazze come sono
una famigliola si spostasse da una
località sciistica e l'altra in
continuazione
il vortice tipo ti porta a fare delle
cose nuove esperienze diverse che escono
dal tuo campo d'azione incontri persone
che mai avresti pensato di incontrare in
vita tua e se sarà una persona curiosa
come me che alletta nel vortice è
rischiosissimo e tu lo sai perché tutti
ti vogliono tutti ti cercano tutti
veramente vogliono una parte di te per i
risultati che ha ottenuto i risultati
che è una vita che lavoro per ottenere
questi risultati
il vortice di dall'inizio un senso di
felicità ma quando passa rimani
veramente vuoto c'è il vuoto
io ho deciso di accorpare tutti gli
impegni ad aprile subito dopo finita la
stagione per poi non aver troppi
ingerenze quando avrei ripreso la
preparazione atletica per questa
stagione che sta per venire
il vortice ma colpito in pieno come
un'onda gigantesca che mi si è infranta
addosso e io non ho non sono riuscita a
fruirne il cambiamento perché questa
volta il cambiamento è stato troppo
radicale dopotutto in una stagione
ottenuto penso tanti risultati quanti
quelli per cui un discreto sciatore si
riterrebbe soddisfatto guardandosi
indietro a fine carriera
io ho ottenuto tutti questi risultati in
una sola stagione senza aver fatto
neanche mai un minimo podio prima la mia
vita è cambiata da così a così il
cambiamento è stato radicalismo e più
radicali il cambiamento più tu devi
saper di adattarli alla nuova situazione
solo che ho fatto l'errore di farmi
travolgere quando ero in quell onda in
quel vortice ero veramente travolta
succhio dal vortice neo nell'occhio del
ciclone ho perso il contatto con me
stessa con la realtà è stato difficile
ma il vortice dopotutto ce l'ho avuto
perché è stato la naturale conseguenza
di di quello che ho fatti tanti di
quello che ho fatto di buono degli
ottimi risultati dei risultati per come
una vita che lavoro e quindi cosa fai
quando sai che il vortice e lì è sempre
di conte e la nuova dimensione in cui tu
dovrai vivere cerchi di ripartire da
quelle consapevolezze da cui il vortice
stesso cerca di allontanarti cerchi di
rito parte stesso esattamente come ho
fatto
il 16 febbraio del 2017 tra la prima e
la seconda manche del gigante dei
mondiali sono arrivata ai mondiali
quest'anno non più da outsider ma da
favorita sono la prima italiana dove ha
fatto podio in quattro discipline su
cinque
avevo fallite super g così anche la
difesa la combinata gigante era l'ultima
cartuccia che avevo l'ultima chance mi
sono messa tra la prima e la seconda
manche quando io comunque seconda vicino
al cancelletto di partenza fino alla
rete guardavo le atlete scendere prima
di me e mi sono guardata dentro e ho
parlato con questa bambina che sono io e
mi son detta sofia arresti mai detto di
essere qua
ai mondiali di poter ter a giocare il
tuo sogno è qui adesso vai esci da quel
cancelletto cerca di circola gioè che va
senza di contraddistingue riparti da
quella passione che ai pc senza avere la
paura di sbagliare senza la paura di
vincere senza aver la paura di essere
giudicate perché già esser qui è un
successo allora fallo per te per la tua
passione per il tuo divertimento
per l'italia sono riuscito a da quel
cancelletto ha fatto la medaglia
esattamente come quel piccolo vortice
che ho avuto febbraio dove avevo
tantissima pressione perché avevo il
peso di una nazione sulle spalle
chiaramente che altre mie compagne però
tanti occhi erano puntati su di me in
quel momento guardando le altre scendere
pensando parlando con questa bambina
sono riuscita fa ad amalgamarli near
dentro di me
due mondi che mentalmente opposti la
pressione che avevo e la passione ed è
proprio così come quel giorno sono
riuscita a far medaglia ripartendo da
questa bambina
la passione è stata la consapevolezza da
cui sono partita per uscire dal vortice
perché senza questa passione che voi
probabilmente non noterete in questa
bambina che sorride felice che alla
coppa in mano senza questa passione io
non sarei qui oggi e senza quella
passione che è la forza indomita che da
sempre ci spinge la spingeva mi spinge
lei sognava iodio degli obiettivi non
saremmo qui senza la passione poi chiaro
io adesso sono una ragazza di 25 anni
sono un atleta matura e per quanto
l'atleta inserito nei sistemi della
federazione della squadra di
appartenenza sia protetto da loro deve
avere un buonissimo grado di
intraprendenza e questo ve lo dico
perché a un certo punto all'atleta
matula in sala consapevolezza di saper
solo lui cosa sia il meglio per se devi
essere intraprendente devi avere occhi
nuovi deve avere una mente aperta pronta
a farti cogliere piccole sfumature
piccoli dettagli che possano far fare
grandi differenze e questo ve lo dico
perchè perchè in un centesimo di secondo
che non è nulla un centesimo di secondo
a volte la differenza tra la gloria e
l'oblio
e niente eppure tutto e io mi gioco la
mia vita
su questo piccolo labile confine e
inoltre chiaramente devi essere
estremamente concreto perché una volta
che ci di essere intraprendenti fissi
dagli obiettivi
devi lavorare giornalmente giorno per
giorno cercare della mente di fare il
tuo meglio per quelli che sono gli
obiettivi della giornata
mi alzo la mattina mi guardo allo
specchio mi chiedo ciò che mi sono
prefissata di fare oggi sarà veramente
il percorso migliore di avvicinamento
verso i miei obiettivi
e questo lo condivido anche con tutto lo
staff di persone che mi aiutano a
concretizzare ea raggiungere mio sogno
questa è la mia vita la mia vita è
veramente cambiata moltissimo
cosa mi aspetterà adesso vi chiederete
ormai ho imparato a convivere col
vortice anzi ben venga vuol dire che ci
sarà sempre buoni risultati ma la realtà
è che nonostante la mia vita sia molto
cambiata l'essenza della mia vita sempre
quella fatta sempre di sogni obiettivi e
lavoro il vortice cerca sempre di
mettermi addosso tantissima pressione
pensate che ormai da mesi vivo convivo
con domande di giornalisti che mi
chiedono sofia riuscirai a riconfermarti
la prossima stagione
oppure sofia goggia vinto le uniche due
gare di coppa del mondo che si sono
disputate sulla pista preolimpica
incorre ansa è la favorita per le
olimpiadi
io convivo con queste domande
con questo vortice ma ho preso una cosa
leggendo il libro di nadia comaneci uno
dei miei preferiti letters to ayane
gymnastic che la pressione non esiste la
pressione siete solo nel momento in cui
tu decidi di di concentrati sulle cose
occhiali che hai da fare quindi ogni
giorno io cerco di concentrarmi su di
esse e sapete adesso what's next forni
c'è sempre questo il cancelletto il
cancelletto da cui uscivo quando avevo 8
anni e il cancelletto di coppa del mondo
che forse sul pinocchio degli sci per la
gara sociale o per la coppa del mondo è
sempre quello e io in partenza però
sempre questo gesto
in questo momento sono qui è il mio rito
mi aiuta veramente a concentrarmi sulle
cose essenziali che devo fare in quel
momento perché non posso permettermi di
pensare ad altro
ma non perché non voglio pensare ad
altro perché voglio concentrarmi solo
sulle cose che ho da fare in quel
momento
questo è quello che voglio il mio
obiettivo per la prossima stagione sarà
sempre quello di presentarmi al
cancelletto tranquilla consapevole e mi
auguro veramente di star sempre in me
stessa e nel momento la mia vita è
cambiata radicalmente la dimensione in
cui vivo è cambiata il vortice ormai al
mio compagno di viaggio ma quello che
rimane sono i miei sogni e la mia
passione
grazie
[Applauso]